- Hi, I'm Shannon from Khan Academy,
and I want to show you
how to make the most
of your learning time.
First, make sure you're logged in
to your Khan Academy account
by checking for your name in
the upper right hand corner.
Now on the left side,
you should see your classes
where your teacher has
given you a mastery goal,
or assignment to work on.
Click on the tab that says Course mastery
to view the goal your teacher set for you.
Now that you're viewing your goal,
let's talk about the
top five things to know
about working towards Course
mastery on Khan Academy.
Number one, your course mastery placement
is a big goal from your teacher.
On your learner home page,
you can see the progress
you've already made
towards your mastery goal,
and the due date your teacher set.
But you can always work ahead,
or view past goals.
Click on the mastery goal
to be taken to the course homepage.
Here, you'll see the units
that make up the course,
as well as your progress
towards mastery on each unit.
As you make progress on each unit,
you'll see the purple bar
fill from left to right.
It's helpful to regularly
check your unit progress,
so you know if you're on
track to meet your goal.
Click into a unit to view
your current mastery level
for each skill on the left-hand side.
With every skill,
try to get the crown,
and move your mastery level to Mastered.
Number two, mastery
takes time and practice.
As you practice skills
and answer questions,
your mastery level for
each skill will go up,
if you answered correctly,
or down, if you miss questions.
If you want to make progress more quickly,
try a Mastery challenge.
Mastery challenges allow
you to strengthen the skills
you've already practiced
in just six questions.
Mastery is not easily earned,
and that's intentional!
But putting in the work to achieve mastery
will prove you've earned and learned it.
Remember, you can retry an exercise
as many times as you'd like
until you earn a score you're happy with.
(stars twinkling)
Struggles and mistakes are
what helps your brain grow.
(congratulatory sound)
Number three, follow the blue button.
Your big goal has a lot
of skills you can practice
at your own pace.
To make sure you stay on track,
look for the blue buttons
throughout the course.
The blue buttons will always guide you
to what you should work on next.
Number four, if you're stuck, take a hint.
It's normal to feel stuck when
you're learning new skills.
The important thing is you don't give up.
Take a hint to get
step-by-step instructions
to the specific question
you're working on.
And write them down so you
can reference them later.
You can also try watching a video,
or reading an article on the skill.
Once you've done that,
you're ready to retry the exercise.
And if you're still stuck,
reach out to your classmate, a teacher,
or a family member for support.
(stars twinkling)
Number five, the sky's the limit!
Remember, you have the
potential to succeed.
Keep trying, keep making mistakes,
and keep asking for help when you need it.
There is no limit to what you can learn.